syndicat de salariés dans la rue et
colère qui monte un contraste avec les
organisations patronales mais des
fessées PME qui se réjouissent du
passage de cette réforme on en parle
avec mon invité Bernard Ribert bonjour
bonsoir vous êtes le vice-président
national de la CPME votre organisation
regroupe des PME et les TPE elle s'est
toujours déclarée favorable à la réforme
sur le fond sur la forme un projet aussi
mal voté avec une opposition majoritaire
de l'opinion publique et ce que ça nous
questionne pas
ça nous questionne surtout pour les
entreprises dans la mesure où elles
pourraient subir effectivement les
conditions d'un durcissement
des manifestations et finalement un
blocage de l'économie en cela
effectivement on peut être inquiet ce
que le président de la République nous a
dit hier c'est que effectivement il y
avait probablement eu un déficit
d'explication en tout cas il a exécutif
n'a pas su convaincre ça effectivement
on l'a bien entendu mais ce que je
voudrais aussi vous dire effectivement
on a toujours et depuis de nombreuses
années étaient favorables à cette
réforme alors dans la forme on pourra en
parler mais sur le fond si vous voulez
je crois que clairement chacun comprend
y compris les organisations syndicales
avec lesquels on est en dialogue
permanent et je rappellerai de deux ou
trois choses à savoir que notamment
pendant cette période effectivement
troublée on n'a pas on n'a pas
interrompu le dialogue avec avec les
organisations syndicales et dure après
si vous aurez peut-être pas échappé que
nous avons conclu pendant cette période
compliquée une réforme notamment et qui
est sur le partage de la valeur ce qui
prouve bien que on faut que les
partenaires sociaux et le président de
la République l'a dit hier nous sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui contredit
aussi ce qu'il a dit le fait qu'il y
avait pas eu de
compromis qui a été proposé par les
syndicats à aucun moment de la part du
gouvernement la question de
l'augmentation des cotisations sociales
ou patronales n'a été envisagée la CFE
CGC dont on parlait tout à l'heure
propose propose à elle dans son dans un
projet de réforme des retraites quelques
euros par mois par salarié et puis aussi
du côté patronal en quoi est-ce vraiment
impossible par le quelques euros à
mettre en place c'est très intéressant
la question que vous posez parce que
précisément dans le régime des retraites
parallèlement vous avez un système qui
s'appelle agir Carco qui concerne
aujourd'hui 13 millions de retraités
donc l'essentiel des retraités du
secteur privé et on a redistribué l'an
dernier quelque chose comme 85 milliards
de retraites complémentaires ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que ça on en parle
pas parce qu'il y a un principe de
réalité qui est celui que nous avons
interdiction avec les partenaires
sociaux de faire du déficit par
conséquent cette règle d'or dans le cas
du paritarisme elle fonctionne et
finalement ce que les Français doivent
entendre c'est que on est capable nous
partenaires sociaux de faire des
compromis je crois qu'on en appelle
souvent à l'exemple allemand ou à des
pays qui sont dans une capacité de
dialogue nous sommes convaincus nous à
la CPME qu'on peut effectivement
progresser de cette façon là dans les
réformes alors le corollaire de cette
réforme des retraites c'est le travail
des seniors l'index senior fait partie
du package de la réforme sont réelles
contraintes pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui
seulement 56% des 55 64 ans sont dans
une situation d'emploi cette inférieure
à la moyenne européenne qui est elle à
60% que propose une organisation comme
la vôtre pour garantir un plus fort taux
d'emploi des seniors alors la première
des choses que je voudrais vous dire que
vraiment affirmer ce que nous pensons à
la PME c'est que nos seniors c'est une
richesse pour nos entreprises moi je
dirige une entreprise artisanale un
collaborateur qui a une expérience
extraordinaire on peut pas s'en peut pas
s'en passer les dispositifs qu'on
prévalus effectivement pour les réformer
il faut ça concerne essentiellement
malheureusement les secteurs du
tertiaire le secteur bancaire
l'assurantielle etc ou là effectivement
ces dispositifs ont privilégié
finalement le départ prématuré de ses
collaborateurs dans les TPEPME ça n'est
pas possible et voyez aujourd'hui ce que
je voudrais vous dire tout simplement
c'est très simple c'est que pendant la
crise covid
on redoutait de perdre nos clients
aujourd'hui ce qu'on regrette c'est de
ne pas trouver de colère donc on peut
pas se passer de ces gens-là de cette
expérience là donc la démographie va
vous aider de l'autre côté du spectre il
y a les jeunes plus de seigneurs au
travail est-ce que c'est moins de place
pour les jeunes c'est ce qui dénonce en
tout cas sachant qu'aujourd'hui le
premier emploi véritable n'est obtenu
pour le jeûne en moyenne qu'à 27 ans que
faire pour garantir là aussi
il vous aura pas échappé que le
développement de l'apprentissage et de
l'alternance a connu un essor
considérable c'est-à-dire que on est
au-delà du million d'apprentis quand il
y a encore quelques années nous étions à
peine à 300000 la question qui vraiment
se pose c'est le problème des ruptures
en cours de contrat on a 20% de taux de
rupture de contrat c'est trop et ça
signifie une chose si vous voulez c'est
que malheureusement on a encore un
déficit d'orientation mais pour autant
c'est les jeunes qui sont quand le pied
à l'étrier par l'emploi par l'expérience
dans l'entreprise je crois que c'est une
grande chance pour la France pour que
précisément résorbe une partie de ce
chômage des jeunes merci Bernard Hibert
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous